Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter One, Episode Five: Denmark in Europe and the oil crisis, from 1972 to 1990.
After the golden years of the sixties, the story takes a turn.
Denmark became a member of the European Community, the EF, which was the forerunner of the present-day EU, in 1973.
And at the beginning of the 1970s, after many years of good economy and growth, Denmark, like many other countries, was hit by economic crisis.
The 1970s and 1980s became a period for Denmark of low economic growth, and of new political parties and movements.
Let's begin with Europe.
In 1958, France, Italy, Germany and the Benelux countries, that is Belgium, the Netherlands and Luxembourg, began an economic cooperation, which developed into the European Community, the EF, and later into the European Union, the EU.
The purpose of the EF was to strengthen trade between the member countries, and to secure peace through strong cooperation.
Therefore, a common market was to be created between the EF countries, without customs borders or other obstacles to mutual trade.
The goal was also that all inhabitants should be free to seek and take work in other EF countries.
On the first of January, 1973, Denmark entered the EF.
A majority of sixty-three point three percent of the voters had said yes to membership in a referendum in October 1972.
In the run-up to the referendum, there was much debate on the EF question.
The supporters thought Denmark would become richer by taking part in the European economic cooperation.
They expected, first, that Denmark's then most important trading partner, Great Britain, would also join the EF together with Denmark.
Further, they wanted to secure the best possible opportunities to trade on the European market, and not least the German one, whose importance for the Danish economy had grown strongly in the preceding years.
In addition, it was an advantage to secure Danish agriculture access to the EF's agricultural support.
The opponents were against Denmark giving up some of its right to decide for itself.
They were afraid that the big countries would come to decide too much, and that membership would harm public welfare and Danish national identity.
Prime Minister Jens Otto Krag signed the Treaty of Rome in Brussels on the twenty-second of January, 1972.
Consideration for exports and the economy became decisive for the Danish yes.
Great Britain and Ireland became members of the EF at the same time as Denmark.
In 1986 there was a new referendum on strengthening cooperation in the EF.
The vote was about the European Single Act, or the "EF package", as it came to be called in Denmark.
Its purpose was to carry out an internal market, where goods, persons, services and capital could move freely across the borders between the member countries.
A majority of Danes, fifty-six point two percent, voted yes.
Now, the oil.
In 1974, Denmark, like many other Western countries, was hit by an economic crisis.
It was triggered by oil prices rising violently in 1973.
The background was that the Arab countries markedly increased the price of oil to put pressure on the Western countries that supported Israel in a war against Egypt and Syria, the Yom Kippur War.
Oil was absolutely crucial for the economy, as it was needed in most of industry, for cars and for heating homes.
Denmark at that time produced very little oil itself, which therefore had to be bought abroad.
So the price increase gave serious problems in Denmark, which already had a deficit in trade with other countries.
The previous years' high economic growth fell considerably, prices in the shops rose very quickly, many became unemployed, and the surplus on the state budget was turned into a deficit.
The problems were made worse and prolonged when another violent price increase on oil happened in 1979 to 80, due to unrest in Iran in connection with the Islamic revolution and the subsequent war between Iran and Iraq.
During the 1980s, the price of oil fell again, because more oil was extracted outside the Middle East, for example in the North Sea, and because part of the world's consumption of oil was replaced by other forms of energy, for example natural gas, coal, nuclear power and, to a much smaller extent, renewable energy sources such as wind power or solar energy.
Further, the oil crises contributed to creating an interest in energy-saving measures, such as better insulation of homes, and the development of cars and electronics, among others TV sets, fridges and freezers, that use energy more efficiently.
Next: a political earthquake.
The 1970s were also a period of big political changes in Denmark.
Many voters protested against high taxes and against the bureaucracy that had followed with the large public sector in the welfare society, and voters got greater distrust of the politicians.
At the general election in 1973, voters suddenly voted markedly differently from before.
It was a big landslide, and this election is therefore called the Landslide Election, Jordskredsvalget.
The Social Democrats, the Social Liberal Party, Venstre, the Conservative People's Party and SF, the five parties then in the Folketing, all got far fewer votes.
Before the Landslide Election, ninety-three percent of voters had voted for one of the five parties.
After the election, it was only sixty-four percent.
Instead, voters voted five more parties into the Folketing, of which the largest was the protest party, the Progress Party, Fremskridtspartiet, which got sixteen percent of the votes, with the lawyer Mogens Glistrup at the head.
The party's main causes were to abolish income tax and public bureaucracy.
Many of the old parties' voters gradually returned over the next years, and none of the new parties that were elected in 1973 are still in the Folketing.
But the Landslide Election is a milestone in Danish political history, among other things because afterwards, between seven and twelve parties have been elected to the Folketing at each election, rather than typically five or six before 1973.
Even though new parties have continually emerged, it has always been politicians from either the Social Democrats, the Social Liberal Party, the Conservative People's Party or Venstre who have been prime ministers in Denmark since the Change of System in 1901.
In the 1970s, successive Danish governments tried to turn around the economic downturn, but without much success.
At the beginning of the 1980s, Denmark had a large deficit on the trade balance, that is, the relation between the value of what Denmark buys and sells abroad.
At the same time, around ten percent of the labour force was out of work.
An important cause of the economic crisis was a large debt to other countries.
The Social Democrats had, with only shorter interruptions, sat in government and held the prime minister's post most of the time since 1929.
But in 1982, because of difficulties solving the economic problems, they left government power to the centre-right wing, without there having been a general election.
The prime minister became the conservative Poul Schlüter, who was prime minister for more than ten years, until 1993.
Poul Schlüter is the first and so far only prime minister from the Conservative People's Party.
This is because Venstre has most of the time been the largest centre-right party since the Change of System in 1901, and therefore has normally held the prime minister's post when there have been centre-right governments after 1901.
The change of government in 1982 is, furthermore, a historic milestone, because the centre-right parties have since most often been in power.
In the period 1982 to 2022, the centre-right parties Venstre and the Conservative People's Party together sat in government and held the prime minister's post for a total of twenty-four years, and the Social Democrats for a total of sixteen years.
The Schlüter government gradually managed to improve the Danish economy, especially in the second half of the 1980s.
The price was record-high unemployment at the start of the 1990s.
But inflation, the price increases, which had been a big problem in the 1970s, fell, and from 1990 there was a surplus on the trade balance against other countries.
This meant that healthy economic growth could get going.
In this context, it also helped that Denmark became more self-sufficient in oil from the North Sea.
The Schlüter government also abolished DR's monopoly, that is its exclusive right, to broadcast Danish TV, which DR had had since the first Danish television broadcast in 1948.
In 1986 it was thus made legal for private parties to own TV channels, and the same year the Folketing decided to establish TV 2, which broadcast for the first time in 1988.
In the following years, the number of radio and TV channels in Denmark grew considerably, and cable and satellite TV with many foreign channels became a significant part of the Danish media picture.
And finally, movements from the grass roots.
After women had begun to come out onto the labour market from the middle of the 1960s, many women in the 1970s demanded more equality as a continuation of this.
For example, women in the Red Stocking movement, rødstrømpebevægelsen, fought through political actions for better conditions for women.
Throughout the 1970s, equality was a very hot political topic.
In 1976, the Folketing, on the basis of an EF directive, passed a law on equal pay for the same work.
Free access to abortion was another of the women's movement's political goals.
Previously it had only been possible to get an abortion if there was a special reason, for example consideration for the woman's health.
But in 1973 the Folketing decided that Danish women should themselves be able to choose whether to terminate a pregnancy.
Until the twelfth week of pregnancy, women could freely choose to have an abortion.
Opposition to free abortion was a significant reason why the Christian People's Party, which is now called the Christian Democrats, was formed and elected to the Folketing in 1973.
But free abortion still applies, and in 2025 the limit for free abortion was raised from the twelfth to the eighteenth week of pregnancy.
Several grassroots movements were very active in the 1970s.
Grassroots movements were usually groups that worked to achieve one particular political goal.
The peace movement was active in this period, and worked, among other things, against military armament and the arms race between the great powers.
Thousands of Danes also demonstrated against nuclear power.
The popular resistance was an important reason why the Folketing in 1985 decided to plan the future energy supply in Denmark without nuclear power.
Not least a serious accident at the nuclear power plant Chernobyl in the Soviet Union, in present-day Ukraine, the year after, in 1986, has been of great importance for the later reluctance towards nuclear power.
The anti-nuclear power movement's international emblem originates from the Danish branch of the movement.
The latest years' climate crisis and high energy prices have, however, created a renewed political discussion on whether Denmark should nevertheless introduce nuclear power in some form, just as a larger part of the population has become more positive towards nuclear power.
Here's your recap for Episode Five.
Poul Schlüter belonged to the Conservative People's Party, and is its only prime minister.
DR's monopoly on television ended in 1986, in the 1980s.
The Landslide Election happened because many voters voted for new parties.
The oil crises were in the 1970s.
The EF began in 1958 and Denmark joined on the first of January, 1973, after a sixty-three point three percent yes vote in October 1972.
The 1986 vote on the Single Act: fifty-six point two percent yes.
The oil crisis began in 1973 to 74, with a second wave in 1979 to 80.
The Landslide Election was in 1973: from ninety-three to sixty-four percent for the five old parties, and the Progress Party took sixteen percent under Mogens Glistrup.
Equal pay law: 1976.
Free abortion up to week twelve: 1973, extended to week eighteen in 2025.
Poul Schlüter was prime minister from 1982 to 1993.
TV 2 started in 1988.
The Folketing decided in 1985 to plan energy without nuclear power.
In the final episode of Chapter One, the Iron Curtain falls, and we reach today.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
What did Danes vote yes to in a referendum in 1972?
Option A: Denmark's entry into the EC.
Option B: Denmark's entry into NATO.
Option C: Denmark's entry into the UN.
[DA] Hvad blev der afholdt en folkeafstemning om i 1972?  A: Danmarks indtræden i EF  |  B: Danmarks indtræden i NATO  |  C: Danmarks indtræden i FN
The answer is A: Denmark's entry into the EC.
It appeared in 4 different exams, most recently in June 2026.
[DA] ✔ A: Danmarks indtræden i EF
Question 2.
Which international organisation did Denmark become a member of in 1973?
Option A: The EC.
Option B: The WTO.
Option C: The OECD.
[DA] Hvilken af følgende internationale organisationer blev Danmark medlem af i 1973?  A: EF  |  B: WTO  |  C: OECD
The answer is A: The EC.
It appeared in the November 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: EF
Question 3.
In which decade was Denmark hit by a multi-year economic crisis triggered by big oil price rises?
Option A: The 1930s.
Option B: The 1950s.
Option C: The 1970s.
[DA] I hvilket årti blev Danmark ramt af en flerårig økonomisk krise, som blev udløst af store prisstigninger på olie?  A: 1930’erne  |  B: 1950’erne  |  C: 1970’erne
The answer is C: The 1970s.
It appeared in the June 2022, November 2024 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: 1970’erne
Question 4.
Why is the 1973 general election called the Landslide Election, Jordskredsvalget?
Option A: Because more women than men were elected to the Folketing.
Option B: Because many voters voted for new parties.
Option C: Because the Social Democrats achieved an absolute majority.
[DA] Hvorfor kaldes folketingsvalget i 1973 for Jordskredsvalget?  A: Fordi der blev valgt flere kvinder end mænd til Folketinget  |  B: Fordi der var mange vælgere, der stemte på nye partier  |  C: Fordi Socialdemokratiet opnåede absolut flertal
The answer is B: Because many voters voted for new parties.
It appeared in the June 2020, November 2021 and May 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Fordi der var mange vælgere, der stemte på nye partier
Question 5.
Which party was Poul Schlüter chairman of when he was prime minister from 1982 to 1993?
Option A: Venstre.
Option B: The Social Democrats.
Option C: The Conservative People's Party.
[DA] Hvilket parti var Poul Schlüter formand for, da han var statsminister i perioden 1982-1993?  A: Venstre  |  B: Socialdemokratiet  |  C: Det Konservative Folkeparti
The answer is C: The Conservative People's Party.
It appeared in the June 2021, June 2022 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Det Konservative Folkeparti
Question 6.
Which party has held the prime minister's post for the most years in total since the Change of System in 1901?
Option A: Venstre.
Option B: The Conservative People's Party.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende partier har haft statsministerposten i sammenlagt flest år siden systemskiftet i 1901?  A: Venstre  |  B: Det Konservative Folkeparti
The answer is A: Venstre.
It appeared in the November 2022 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Venstre
Question 7.
In which decade did the monopoly of Danmarks Radio, and thereby its exclusive right to broadcast Danish TV, end?
Option A: The 1940s.
Option B: The 1960s.
Option C: The 1980s.
[DA] I hvilket årti ophørte Danmarks Radios monopol og dermed eneretten til at sende dansk tv?  A: 1940’erne  |  B: 1960’erne  |  C: 1980’erne
The answer is C: The 1980s.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: 1980’erne
Question 8.
When was free abortion introduced?
Option A: 1935.
Option B: 1951.
Option C: 1973.
[DA] Hvornår blev der indført fri abort?  A: 1935  |  B: 1951  |  C: 1973
The answer is C: 1973.
It appeared in the November 2020 and June 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: 1973
Question 9.
What change came into force in 2025 regarding free abortion?
Option A: The limit for free abortion was raised from twelve to eighteen weeks.
Option B: The limit for free abortion was lowered from twelve to nine weeks.
[DA] Hvilken ændring trådte i kraft i 2025 angående den fri abort?  A: Grænsen for fri abort blev hævet fra 12 til 18 uger  |  B: Grænsen for fri abort blev sænket fra 12 til 9 uger
The answer is A: The limit for free abortion was raised from twelve to eighteen weeks.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Grænsen for fri abort blev hævet fra 12 til 18 uger
Question 10.
What did the Red Stocking movement work for, among other things?
Option A: Equality between men and women.
Option B: Introduction of twelve years of basic schooling.
Option C: Old-age pension for everyone.
[DA] Hvad arbejdede rødstrømpebevægelsen blandt andet for?  A: Ligestilling mellem mænd og kvinder  |  B: Indførelse af 12 års grundskole  |  C: Folkepension til alle
The answer is A: Equality between men and women.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Ligestilling mellem mænd og kvinder
Question 11.
Which political movement was the Red Stocking movement part of?
Option A: The labour movement of the 1930s.
Option B: The women's movement of the 1970s.
Option C: The environmental movement of the 1990s.
[DA] Hvilken politisk bevægelse var rødstrømpebevægelsen en del af?  A: Arbejderbevægelsen i 30’erne  |  B: Kvindebevægelsen i 70’erne  |  C: Miljøbevægelsen i 90’erne
The answer is B: The women's movement of the 1970s.
It appeared in the May 2023 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Kvindebevægelsen i 70’erne
Question 12.
Is there a rule in Danish law that an employer must give women and men equal pay for the same work?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Er der i dansk lov en regel om, at en arbejdsgiver skal give kvinder og mænd lige løn for samme arbejde?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
That's the end of this part.
Well done.